before we begin since this is a bbc
owned property i feel the need to point
out that the news arm of the bbc has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pin comment below various
videos from both myself and other
youtubers covering this issue and while
i understand that the doctor who
creative team is not responsible for
this i will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
wow
looks like chipnel's resolution was to
write a better script
[Music]
hey folks series 11 is behind us but
before i can do a revisit of series 12
i'm not doing flux right after that i
need more time and distance from it
before i'm prepared to do that but first
i need to deal with resolution the first
doctor who new year's special as opposed
to christmas special and yeah as the
intro implied
this is one of the better chris chibnall
scripts i actually think he's done
pretty well with the new year's specials
which at this point kind of form a
little bit of a loose trilogy
uh but it they just feel
like they've got a heck of a lot more
energy to them and or rather it captures
that energy that is in the episodes that
i like even though there are other
things about those episodes that i don't
like so i've brought up like enjoying
the vibe and the energy on more
propellant stories like the ghost
monument or curblam because i honestly
think chimnel's writing is at its best
when it has good momentum
when it's stalled out and it's not
really aggressively moving forward and
like it's taking its time setting you
know setting time aside to explain and
like delve into things
it doesn't work now does that mean that
it is devoid of problems no but
i find that the problems that tend to
show up in the more propellant and
energetic episodes
they tend not to bother me so much
because the vibe is working for me i can
i can be forgiving there's still stuff
that's off about this
and i know there's some people who are
more hung up on continuity and specifics
or who find specific moments incredibly
egregious or at least memeable and very
easy to make fun of and i'm not going to
defend any of those things
uh but they don't dampen my fun
so
where do we start with this
actually the cold open why don't we
start with that i'd forgotten there was
a cold open to this thing
that it starts with this whole ancient
battle
ancient foe split into three parts taken
around the world it's very weird
actually and
ultimately
deeply unnecessary
for all intents and purposes the story
would be identical
if the dalek had suddenly had simply
been one dalek killed and buried
somewhere
uh you know they were trying to take it
to the end of the earth or whatever you
know just
just died
that
would effectively be the exact same
thing and it would take away a lot of
logistical questions because like
seriously the descendants of these
people just
sat next to these burial sites
for
however long
and with stuff like axes and swords like
as time has moved forward they haven't
gotten
guns maybe i
it's silly and it's deeply unnecessary
and that's that that's about the
about the worst as far as this goes
because like there are these little
moments diverges like that is really
unnecessary but they're also pretty
quick because like
i feel like in a chimneal story that
isn't working on moving forward and
giving a good sense of tension
that
a lot more time would have been spent
you know talking about this ancient
order of
that they even named them i can't even
remember what it is because it doesn't
matter
they shouldn't be there at all but not
too much time is spent on them so as
weird as the cold open is
we move on
and i kind of like the idea of the
doctor taking the companions like to all
these different versions of new years uh
i kind of find that fun
i also kind of like that the doctor has
like an earth alert
in the turret it's just like oh it's
just a leave a little alarm on as it's
your home just in case
oh that's bad because it does feel like
by this point
the doctor should have that and probably
should have installed it a while ago so
i kind of like that that works for me
the uh the two archaeologists who are uh
at the dig site and um end up uncovering
the dalek
they work pretty well uh right off at
the intro that's not necessarily great
writing the writing's fine the
performers have good chemistry they are
good both playing off each other in the
sort of early stages of a romantic
interest thing but beyond that they're
both very good at projecting a sense of
like the wants and needs and what drives
these people so they don't just feel
like they're there to fulfill
the narrative function of uncovering the
dalek they feel a little bit more
fleshed out than that largely due to the
performances and
that helps as well
now okay we gotta talk about the
reconnaissance dalek
i know there are some people out there
who don't like the reconnaissance dalek
they don't like that it tinkers with the
lore of what daleks could be or what
they're capable of
personally speaking
i really don't care about any of that
it gets a unique name which means it
doesn't have to obey the same sort of
rules and limitations of other daleks it
can have other capabilities is it
ridiculous that it somehow managed to
revive and like teleport its other three
parts of itself into one place yes that
is ridiculous
but it's doctor who that's
that's how we're getting to the story
and the idea that these like were the
first to leave scaro
i don't i could have sworn they actually
said this in the episode i guess they
didn't maybe it's my head cannon in my
head cannon like these
these things are sent off and they work
alone and then call in the fleet largely
because they've been genetically altered
so much that it's kind of questionable
how much how proper dalek they are
because the daleks are very into genetic
purity because they're nazis
so
that uh whole aspect in my head is like
well that's why they send them off on
their own because they don't actually
the daleks find a find the
reconnaissance daleks very useful but
don't actually want them around um so
you know send them off do their thing
and then send them off somewhere else
that's my head cannon at least
but i like the idea that he's puppeting
this woman she does a really good job in
performing you know you can see the
switch when like the dog is more in
complete control and she gets very
menacing in the body language but then
when she's fighting she's fighting
against it it changes she actually does
really good work in in this
um i suppose it's worth mentioning at
this point the uh
the body count or the kill specifically
because there's there's one in here
i've railed against before and i will
bring it up again cause it's it's still
real bad so initially
we've got uh two cops who get killed um
because they pull her over for speeding
then the dalek kills them that is i it's
not necessary to have a b2 it could have
been one although i don't know maybe uh
in england the cops have to have a
ride-along and it's not ever just one
cop in a car so maybe it did have to be
two i like i honestly don't know
but
they died to establish that even outside
of its casing even just in control and
attached to this woman the dalek is
still deadly cool there is a reason to
do that
then
we have the somewhat notorious kill
where
uh it rocks up to where its
pew pew laser is and
there's a guard there who basically the
only thing we learn about him is that
he's gay and then he's dead
more secure digits in yorkshire that's
what tell me boyfriend anyway
it's not great
it's not great
it is a pretty bad example of
uh barrier gays now an accidental one i
have i'm very confident uh in that
assessment because this is basically the
same thing as what happened to the
grandfather back in the morning fell to
earth let's establish one thing about
this person and then kill them because
in theory like it
makes them more than one note except it
doesn't it just gives them that one note
as opposed to just being a body to kill
and i don't see why the dolly couldn't
have just figured a way to bust into it
without killing anybody but you know
deciding that his one trait we're gonna
find out about him is gay
not great and i think actually it's
funny because there's the third guy who
gets killed at like this scrap yard uh
where the dalek ends up rebuilding its
casing
he actually kind of makes the case that
this like giving these characters these
one random traits is deeply unnecessary
because this guy doesn't get one he
doesn't get oh here's one thing about me
but he still works because we get a
sense of who he is just through
the job he has the way he dresses and
the way he talks to her humanity will be
destroyed all right
that's enough
you don't have to establish oh by the
way i'm gay
i mean come on
anyways um
moving on from that
i kind of like the rebuilt dalek tank
um i i actually like that the dalek had
to go and recover it's it's i'm just
going to start calling in that this now
the pew pew laser um because it it would
have seemed questionable to me if he
could have rebuilt that because it would
have been my assumption that that is
powered or uses as ammunition something
that is not to be found on earth whereas
you could use metals to
approximate the overall tank so i kind
of like that he had to recover that but
then got to build the rest i kind of dig
that
and then we get towards the tail end i
think uh the way things move forward the
doctor confronting the dalek is pretty
good whitaker does decently like with
the sense of i always think i'm rid of
them she does uh she gives a good sense
of history
uh in her performance when it comes to
confronting the dalek so that worked
pretty well
uh i think the other major thing that i
need to talk about is ryan's father
which i'm a little mixed on
leaning positive
so
if you've seen me go off on the idiot's
lantern or talk about even though it
didn't bother me nearly as much some of
the problems with it takes you away much
as i love that episode
you know that uh troubled family figures
fathers in particular
uh
they seem to be something that i keep
spotting really bad
instances of in doctor who in particular
so
ryan's dad at this point has already
been established as an absentee father
that was established in series 11 proper
so i do like that he doesn't just show
up out of nowhere and it's like wait
what's the deal with this guy the
instant we find out that's right is that
it's like oh
[Music]
so
the groundwork was laid for this pretty
decently
and
i actually think that for the most part
this is handled pretty well
i like that graham just wants him gone i
like that the doctor upon finding out
who this guy is her first thing that she
says him is you work at grace's funeral
and it doesn't come across as like as
she's stating a fact and doesn't realize
the sort of social situation it doesn't
come across as a socially awkward thing
it feels legitimately accusatory
and good for her
because no
he wasn't
and that was pretty messed up
but at the same time i kind of
appreciate that you know graham
later on talking to him
isn't necessarily forgiving of the guy
but he's like look
your mother loved you
here's some of your stuff she kept
around
just don't mess up ryan again is the
reason i'm not the reason i don't like
you and the reason i'm not gonna just
warm to you is because i've seen the
damage you do to him and i also like
that ryan is not naive the most painful
thing that could have
happened
for me would have been if there was a
sense of false hope from ryan instead i
appreciate that he is where he's at
which is that his father's let him down
enough times and over a long enough
stretch of time
the dude just
doesn't get to just stroll back into his
life and say i want to try again
how you been doing
seriously
that's where you start yet at the same
time there is a very genuine sincerity
from the guy and that balance is
important because
and i need to emphasize this
people can change
but a
they need to want to
they need to want to actually change not
just reap the rewards of if they were to
change but they have to actually want to
be a different person
that's the first thing
and second
it
takes
time
not just for them to get better but for
the people around them to see that there
is consistency and they're sticking to
it and to ever be willing to extend an
olive branch again these are important
things to have
and this does have them
right up to the very end
and that's where i get very mixed it
does this doesn't completely wreck it
but i am mixed on this so the whole
thing of the dalek gets on to aaron
that's uh ryan's dad gets onto aaron's
back
and the way the doctor
this is an extreme solution the way the
doctor deals with this is they're on the
tardis takes them like outside to to
like where there's a sun and opens up
the doors and like creates a a little
vacuum funnel to try and suck the dalek
off of him
and
it's not working then ryan you know
basically with the power of love aaron
is able to sort of regain some control
of his body and they win and that's fine
as far as you know somewhat cheesy
resolution goes
where i get iffy is
that ryan seems to be
going into this big expression of
love and potentially even forgiveness
forgiveness
and a second chance and
the faith of people you love
is energizing so as cheesy as it is i
should kind of buy that that would have
given aaron sort of the you know
the ability to to stand his ground
i do buy that because that is powerful
but at the same time even though it's
under fantastical circumstances
i just don't think it's a good idea to
frame
forgiveness and second chances around a
big moment
like i said it's something that has to
happen with time and that's something
that ryan recognizes earlier
but because this is only an hour it
needs to wrap up in a satisfying and
heartwarming way we're going to end on a
big moment
and imply well things will be good from
here forward
that's not how it works
anyone who relies on big moments be they
the person who is seeking a second
chance or be they the person who is
prepared to extend a second chance doing
it in big moments
is in a way like
removes the focus on just do better over
time because
it creates a situation where okay well
if i just do a big enough thing if it's
a big enough moment
then i'll be forgiven again and it can
honestly just lead to backsliding again
it can lead to a cycle
as opposed to just slow and steady
progression forward again i get why it's
there for the sake of narrative
catharsis and this is far from the worst
offender as far as depictions of toxic
family members go
but
i i also don't love it but it is really
just that moment at the end and it
doesn't completely kill it
uh and on rewatch like to my memory the
stuff with ryan and his dad didn't
really work but watching it now i'm like
no
except for that bit at the end that i'm
a little iffy on for the most part this
actually works quite well
i was kind of surprised pleasantly so to
notice that there's a couple of other
little things here and there both good
and bad i like that um yaz is basically
still on people wrangling duty pretty
consistently which fits with her uh
position as a police officer so that
works uh there's a mention on ryan's
dyspraxia again which feels like it
comes out of nowhere because
they realized they hadn't brought it up
in a while okay
and like it doesn't even factor in it's
just he goes not bad for a guy with
dyspraxia huh i'm like yeah i guess not
that's a weird way to put it and there's
also the the somewhat notorious
what the internet's down what do we do
because we'll have to have a
conversation joke which
it's not a good joke but i don't care
like
whatever
it my only issue with it is the setup
drags on a little too long
like
you could have just they could have it
could have been half as long as it is
that scene would it make the joke better
no
not really but it would just eat up less
time and as a joke is like it's
it's dumb but whatever
people got real upset about that joke i
don't i don't actually get why
i guess they feel it's just emblematic
of some of chibnall's writing but it's
like it's just a toss away joke that
doesn't really work so what
but for the most part i really do like
resolution
and for chibnall especially
uh because he is the the credited writer
on this it's a significant step
step off
step off step up
especially uh after battle of runs core
of colos
but resolution what do you think about
it have you re-watched it lately
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it like share and subscribe
patreon that's what pays the bills
and any amount you're able to give is of
great assistance but there are other
ways to support me there are channel
memberships i have merchandise and books
and other things or things like twitch
and tick tock where you can follow me as
well
but
don't worry too much about it
what i really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
all right i've got thanks to give for my
patreon supporters robin moore zubin
fulla turak the thing that goes doink in
the anime oliver b linda walters
imodelkey the oath of boyd tt for nabi
lax the poodle zach idolin tracy
scrabbit angry casper
toku bl whovian adam rdl taylor shane
ross shayla gourley and brendan larose
the rats and i thank you
[Music]